Jim Acosta was sitting 10 feet from me and he bad mouth me saying I
was a PR stunt that I did that he played me directly a
PR stunt to get to promote my pillow.
This is what happened last week. So we got a little rerun here. I mean,
I never thought that my popular fame could grow any
bigger, you know, whatever, infamous fan, whatever you want to call it.
But I get, I start making masks. I converted my whole company,
75% over to make a cloth mask. And it was quite a project.
We had to train all employees, but we did it in like four games.
Can you just explain a little bit about how you do that? I mean,
did you have to bring in experts to change machines? I mean.
I made a call to the vice president's office.
I actually an email and they sent me right away to Peter Navarro and,
and whenever he was running, I didn't know who Peter Navarro was.
And then he emailed me right back and he directed me to a task force.
They had already set up in a little coalition about anybody that was all these
different things from mass to go into whatever kind of like let's set this up so
people can have their questions answered. So I called them the first question.
I said, what are the, what are the measurements? Uh,
is there a restriction that I have to know about?
Because obviously I have to worry about getting sued by frivolous lawyers in
California. Let's not forget that. So I had to make sure everything was,
you know, was right in the meantime, I already said I'm doing this. So my,
my employees, they're very good at scaling. I've had some of the same team.
We're like a big family. We just started going. We took the sewing machines,
moved them, made them eight feet apart. Um, we had to, um,
and to move wracking,
we had to make sure that I had to make sure that we had the right fabric.
It was a blessing. The, my pillow fabric was perfect for it.
We just had to not do two processes of printing and other thing.
So we had to do a different process, but it wasn't a big switch.
And then I had to get a Lastic. I first I bought the wrong elastic and latex.
So I had to dump that, get the right elastic.
There was a low shortage for one day,
but I was determined I was going to get it. And then we, uh, we had a biggest,
really expensive cutting machines so we can cut the patterns.
And we were up and making masks in three days,
everyone was training their uncle get close to 10,000 the first day.
And we, we w we added two shifts or friend of mine. We slot them,
had to be laundry. The commercial line, man. We just,
I was up til 12 every day setting. The foundation is till midnight,
starting again at five in the morning. Well,
then I get an email from the vice president's office and said,
could you come out to do and being involved in a round table,
like I was involved in when the 2017 first time I was ever in the white house
and for me to be in America, well, they said,
we'd like you to help rate some remarks and I'm gone, okay.
They got to get approval. I'm going, what do I need for a round table for?
So I actually, the remarks are here and these are the type ones here.
These are the type remarks. Okay. So I type them up and send them out there.
And I wasn't even real particular.
They wanted remarks of what we were doing and a print specifically about what my
pillow was doing. I'm going okay. I don't really, you know, that's fine.
I don't really need to brag about what I'm doing to help the country,
but I'll do it. You know, it sits in a round table. And, uh,
so I fly out there.
We get to the round table and there's all the five CEOs that are there.
The vice president, a couple of guys down at the end,
I forget who they were and we're we go around the table and each one, well,
this one's doing respirators and this one's. And I said, we're doing mask. And,
but I wasn't looking, nobody was looking at their remarks or whatever.
I didn't even see any papers out and I'm going.
So then the president came in and this is a good half hour of everyone saying
what they're doing, but you guys were, you know, can you make more, uh,
you know, what you, what do you plan? What are your plans? And, and, uh,
we get down to the president, gets up and they all get up.
And I said to the vice president, I said, we didn't read our remarks. He goes,
Oh, no, no, they're outside of the president might call you up to them. Really.
So now we go into the other room towards the oval office and the
president he's showing the other CEOs, you kind of get a little mini tour here.
And then he sits down and he's got to read his speech with the vice president.
And we're sitting over here at this table. And I thought, you know what,
I'm reading the remarks. I go, you know what?
I want to give a message of hope to the people.
And so I start writing on the back and, uh, you know,
if you can see my scribbles, there's little arrows that go down and stuff,
we wrote it. I thought I would rewrite it on a clean piece of paper.
I just get done with the last thing. I mean,
there's crossed out and everything and they go, okay,
we're going out to the Rose garden and I'm going, what? Now? I'm running. Okay.
So all I said was, God, please let me read my writing. That's all I
heard out. The president calls me up first. I mean, I came right up.
We knew practices. So I didn't know we were all going to go around the end.
So he called me up person. I went straight up.
So I think they held the other CEO's back. So it was just him and I,
and here's a guy that has so much nervousness of speaking. Now I did,
uh, my, um, my throat. I've had,
I had vocal cord surgery just a week before I was a little raspy, like I am now.
And, uh, and I get up there and I read them and then I just felt, you know,
let it get turned around. I said, Mr. President,
you mind if I read something off the cuff now? And he said, yes.
And then I read the guy, you know,
God gave us grace on November 18th or November eight, 2016. Um,
you know, I just read that they don't talk to about that. We, uh,
the nation had turned his back on God and we should spend his time and,
you know, reading the Bibles,
getting back on the word and spending time with our families. And I said,
we're all going to get through this with this great administration and
everybody's prayers and everybody combined, we're all in this.
And we're going to be stronger and safer than ever.
You would have think I shot somebody.
So, so you do all this it's impromptu.
He's letting you do your thing. You talk about God, you're, you're,
you're making, I think at one point you were making 50,000 masks a day, right?
Yeah. You're doing doing that right now. So you finish, you finish the speech.
And did you even think about it or realize what was about to come your way?
Like, did it even cross your mind?
No. Do you know what? It was just, it was like, to me it didn't feel that,
you know, it didn't, I didn't think it would be a shot heard round the world.
And, uh, we won't,
we went back into the white house and the first inkling I got that it might be
real big was the vice president came to me and he goes,
he was just wildlife. You know, he goes, you've opened up the, you know,
opened up the habits. I mean, people are gonna, you know, you're just,
it was just, I don't even remember what he said, but he was just,
I could just tell, he just loved it. I'm going good.
I got a little confirmation that it was okay. You know,
the president never said a thing about it. You know,
he was talking to the CEOs and us and, and um, we go to, when I,
when I left the white house, I finally, you got my phone back. See,
they have your phones. Right.
And I open up my phone and turn it on.
I had 750 text messages.
I didn't know that many people had my phone number and I'm going,
what did happen? I looked at Twitter and there's thousands was,
I looked at my peace book. It had blown up. I had 2000 emails. I mean,
it was just, and I'm trying to drive and get to him going. Well,
I had to pull over. I was just gone. I call him Prince. I go, what happened?
They go, don't, you know, everybody's talking about it and I'm going really.
And, uh, so for that point I have,
I've done 80 some interviews as of today, every day, all day,
I've gotten calls from Israel, my friends in Australia,
they said it was on top of all the news in the timeline paper.
It was the cover of their national paper. This was like, you think it was,
and you know, one of the good things there's there.
I'm glad I asked the president because, um, the, everybody knew he had no idea.
You know, he had no ideas. So, you know, people that said, Oh,
you're mixing church and state or church in God or whatever God got in into
government. You know what? I did that. So what are you going to do?
Put me in jail. Sorry. Right.
Well, you didn't, you also,
didn't the government didn't force anyone to listen to you.
People could either hear you and, and, and believe,
or enjoy what you say or not. So be it. Um, but now, okay.
But now talk about just the media reaction,
cause I'm sure you're getting a lot of love from, from nice quarters.
And it must be nice to hear the, vice-president say some nice things,
but really, I mean, I, you know,
I was watching it as it happened on Twitter and the amount of,
of main stream media people.
Who've never donated a dollar given up any of their time. There, all the,
my pillow guy mocking you, uh, mocking Trump for bringing you on.
It's a big stunt, blah, blah. Meanwhile, you're the one. I mean, it costs you,
you don't have to tell me how much,
but I assume it costs you quite a penny to convert the operation. Not only that,
but what you're then not making in pillows.
Oh, absolutely. You know, that was God, the guys,
we have beak of rewarding me for just speaking out his name,
because now when that happened, everybody, you know, we had,
we had laid off a bunch of people that were on the road doing home shows.
I have 90, some people that do home shows and fairs like I used to do. They,
they had lost their jobs because they were closed and my stores were closed.
Well, now they could all get, they could all get on phones.
They're still coming in. You know, they're still coming in. And, uh, and, uh,
but they could get on phones now. And with our business went up, like you say,
for every one attack nine people. It's even more than that.
I think for every one attack, 50 people would go after that guy.
What's wrong with you? You know what I mean? They would tell that guy,
what is wrong with you? Do you do a great things? What have you done?
And these hosts on MSN, Jim Acosta was sitting 10 feet from me now.
And he bad mouth me saying I was a PR stunt that I did that he
played me directly a PR stunt to get to promote my pillow.
Are you kidding? Maybe you didn't listen. Right, Jim? I was promoting Jesus.
If you're looking for more honest and thoughtful conversations about politics,
instead of nonstop yelling, checkout our politics playlist.
And if you want to watch full interviews on a variety of topics,
watch our full episode playlists, all right, over here,
and to get notified of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and click the notification bell.